chacun de nous a bien au moins une fois
dans sa vie assister à cette sorte de
cérémonie étrange appelée défilé
folklorique de laquelle quelques
personnes plus ou moins costumé faisait
sonner cet instrument bizarre et pensçu
au son acidulé qu'on nomme la
vielou nul doute possible alors c'était
bien les gars du Berry ou quelques
morvandot qui défilaient sous nos yeux
tout comme le bignou des bretons ou la
cabrette des enfants de l'Auvergne la
viarou est en effet devenue depuis
quelques décennies un des emblèmes
majeurs d'un certain folklorisme figé et
artificiel
pourtant cet instrument européen par
excellence n'a jamais été jusqu'à une
époque récente spécifique d'une province
déterminée et son histoire prodigieuse
s'il en fut se confond avec celle là
même de l'évolution de nos musiques
occidentales c'est cette histoire là que
nous conte aujourd'hui René
zoso
[Musique]
pour moi la viel la roue c'est d'abord
un instrument qui sans être lié à un
répertoire
précis s'attache autour des reins avec
une courroie et avec lequel on se bat
c'est un instrument qui a commencé
d'exister pense-t-on vers la fin du 10e
début 11e siècle en Espagne
dans la région de saint-jcques de
Compostelle et qui se serait ensuite
diffusé dans le reste de l'Europe sur le
chemin retour du
pèlerinage au début c'était un
instrument beaucoup plus grand à deux
places
l'organistrome un instrument de musique
d'avant-garde un instrument de recherche
musicale c'est un instrument qui est lié
au début de la
polyphonie dans la mesure où il établit
des
bourdons à l'intérieur
desquels va se développer une ligne
[Musique]
mélodique ces bourdons sont
particulièrement importants parce qu'ils
constituent des points fixes dans
lesquels la voix ou la mélodie
instrumentale vont se développer donc le
rapport entre chaque note et le Bourdon
est particulièrement important
il importe donc d'écouter très
attentivement ses bourdons pour se
fondre
dedans et pour ensuite s'en détacher
petit à
petit c'était le début d'un champ
grégorien où la voix part de l'une de
ses notes bourdon pour descendre vers
l'autre notre bourdon on pourrait
imaginer d'autres parcours et ça nous
donnerait les autres modes grégoriens et
alors comment est-ce que cela fonctionne
et bien la
manivelle fait tourner la roue la roue
frotte sur les cordes nous donnant une
note
bourdon
l'autre reprise en
dessus reprise en
dessus et comme la roue est
ronde ces bourons vont durer tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps et
c'est justement sur la base de ces
bourdons qui
durent que peuvent se greffer des
mélodies des instruments par exemple
dans cet extrait des car Burana c'est
sur les bourdon de la vi que vont se
greffer tous les autres instruments de
[Musique]
l'ensemble
jusqu'à présent nous avons parlé des
bourdons il nous reste à parler du
clavier ici nous avons deux cordes qui
passent dans le clavier dans les
premières VI il y en avait trois qui
nous donnait la note la quinte l'octave
la quinte ou la
carte et alors c'est important d'avoir
des touches pour pouvoir jouer sur les
différentes cordes en même
[Musique]
temps
he
[Musique]
GD
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ça c'est l'école NotreDame de
Paris une recherche polyphonique un
champ parallèle sur les deux chantell de
la viel et tout un tas de petites
alluminures vocales rajoutées par-dessus
écrites par perottin
musique d'avant-garde on peut dire
pendant ce temps-là dans le sud de la
France les rapports entre les trouadours
et des musiciens arabes continuent et
cela s'organise toujours autour des
bourdons avec des instruments
divers d'autres instruments à bourdon
comme ce qu'on appelle en France
maintenant l'épinett des vuges et qu'on
a trouvé un peu partout en Hongrie
[Musique]
aussi
li
[Musique]
jor
en
[Musique]
[Musique]
della
lbramour
[Musique]
l mais à partir d'un certain moment les
bourdons se mettent à gêner le
développement de la
polyphonie alors la vielle quitte le
domaine savant pour devenir un
instrument abandonné au peuple au
mendiant au gueux au paysan dans le jeu
populaire on s'en est servi soit pour
des complaintes soit pour danser mais
pour danser manquait un élément
rythmique et on l'invente sous la forme
de ce petit morceau de bois ici qu'on
appelle le chien ou le crapau ou le
Trompillon et alors la corde un des
bourdons la trompette passe sur ce
Trompillon lorsque je tourne à manivelle
les cordes
vibr au moment où je donne un coup elle
vibre plus
fort et le petit bout de bois vibre
aussi et tape contre la table de la
vielle
grésille alors je peux donner un coup
par tour
ou
de
ou 3
[Musique]
ou
4 et
[Musique]
cetera la viel est donc maintenant un
instrument
complet les bourdons les chanterelles et
le rythme un instrument à
danser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]